[Music]
the goal here is simple explain what a
derivative is the thing is though
there's some subtlety to this topic and
a lot of potential for paradoxes if
you're not careful so kind of a
secondary goal is that you have an
appreciation for what those paradoxes
are and how to avoid them
you see it's common for people to say
that the derivative measures an
instantaneous rate of change but when
you think about it that freeze is
actually an oxymoron change is something
that happens between separate points in
time and when you blind yourself to all
but just a single instant there's not
really any room for change you'll see
what I mean more as we get into it but
when you appreciate that a phrase like
instantaneous rate of change is actually
nonsense I think it makes you appreciate
just how clever the fathers of calculus
were in capturing the idea that that
phrase is meant to evoke but with a
perfectly sensible piece of math the
derivatives as our central example I
want you to imagine a car that starts at
some point a speeds up and then slows
down to a stop at some point be a
hundred meters away and let's say it all
happens over the course of ten seconds
that's the set up to have in mind as we
lay out what the derivative is we could
graph this motion letting the vertical
axis represent the distance traveled and
the horizontal axis represent time
so at each time tea represented with a
point somewhere on this horizontal axis
the height of the graph tells us how far
the car has traveled in total after that
amount of time it's pretty common to
name a distance function like this s of
T I would use the letter D for distance
but that guy already has another
full-time job in calculus initially this
curve is quite shallow since the car is
slow to start
during that for a second the distance
that it travels doesn't really change
that much then for the next few seconds
as the car speeds up the distance
traveled in a given second gets larger
which corresponds to a steeper slope in
this graph and then towards the end when
it slows down that curve shallows out
again
and if we were to plot the cars velocity
in meters per second as a function of
time it might look like this bump at
early times the velocity is very small
up to the middle of the journey the car
builds up to some maximum velocity
covering a relatively large distance
each second then it slows back down
towards a speed of 0
and these two curves here are definitely
related to each other right if you
change the specific distance versus time
function you're going to have some
different velocity versus time function
and what we want to understand is the
specifics of that relationship exactly
how does velocity depend on a distance
versus time function
and to do that it's worth taking a
moment to think critically about what
exactly velocity means here intuitively
we all might know what velocity at a
given moment means it's just whatever
the cars speedometer shows in that
moment and intuitively it might make
sense that the cars velocity should be
higher at times when this distance
function is steeper when the cart
reverses more distance per unit time but
the funny thing is velocity at a single
moment makes no sense if I show you a
picture of a car just a snapshot in an
instant and I ask you how fast it's
going
you'd have no way of telling me what
you'd need are two separate points in
time to compare that way you can compute
whatever the change in distance across
those times is divided by the change in
time right I mean that's what velocity
is it's the distance traveled per unit
time so how is it that we're looking at
a function for velocity that only takes
in a single value of T a single snapshot
in time it's weird isn't it we want to
associate individual points in time with
a velocity but actually computing
velocity requires comparing two separate
points in times
if that feels strange and paradoxical
good you're grappling with the same
conflicts that the father's our calculus
did and if you want a deep understanding
for rates of change not just for a
moving car but for all sorts of things
in science you're going to need to
resolve this apparent paradox first I
think it's best to talk about the real
world and then we'll go into a purely
mathematical one let's think about what
the cars speedometer is probably doing
at some point say three seconds into the
journey the speedometer might measure
how far the car goes in a very small
amount of time maybe the distance
traveled between three seconds and 3.01
seconds then it could compute the speed
in meters per second as that tiny
distance traversed in meters divided by
that tiny time 0.01 seconds that is a
physical car just side steps the paradox
and doesn't actually compute speed at a
single point in time it computes speed
during a very small amount of time so
let's call that difference in time DT
which you might think of in this case as
0.01 seconds and let's call that
resulting difference in distance D s so
the velocity at some point in time is DS
divided by DT the tiny change in
distance over the tiny change in time
graphically you can imagine zooming in
on some point of this distance versus
time graph above T equals 3 that DT is a
small step to the right since time is on
the horizontal axis and that DS is the
resulting change in the height of the
graph since the vertical axis represents
the distance traveled so DS divided by
DT is something you can think of as the
rise over run slope between two very
close points on this graph of course
there's nothing special about the value
T equals 3 we could apply this to any
other point in time so we consider this
expression DS over DT to be a function
of T something where I can give you a
time T and you can give me back the
value of this ratio at that time the
velocity as a function of time so for
example when I had the computer draw
this bump curve here the one
representing the velocity function
here's what I had the computer actually
do
first I chose a small value for DT I
think in this case it was 0.01 then I
had the computer look at a whole bunch
of times T between 0 and 10 and compute
the distance function S at T plus DT and
then subtract off the value of that
function at T in other words that's the
difference in the distance traveled
between the given time T and the time
0.01 seconds after that then you can
just divide that difference by the
change in time DT and that gives you a
velocity in meters per second around
each point in time so with a formula
like this you could give the computer
any curve representing any distance
function S of T and it could figure out
the curve representing velocity so that
would be a good time to pause reflect
make sure that this idea of relating
distance to velocity by looking at tiny
changes makes sense because what we're
going to do is tackle the paradox of the
derivatives head-on
this idea of DS over DT a tiny change in
the value of the function s divided by
the tiny change in the input that caused
it that's almost what a derivative is
and even though a car's speedometer will
actually look at a concrete change in
time like 0.01 seconds and even though
the drawing program here is looking at
an actual concrete change in time in
pure math the derivative is not this
ratio dsdt for a specific choice of DT
instead it's whatever that ratio
approaches as your choice for DT
approaches zero luckily there is a
really nice visual understanding for
what it means to ask what this ratio
approaches remember for any specific
choice of DT this ratio D s DT is the
slope of a line passing through two
separate points on the graph right well
as DT approaches zero and as those two
points approach each other the slope of
the line approaches the slope of a line
that's tangent to the graph at whatever
point T were looking at so the true
honest-to-goodness pure math derivative
is not the rise over run slope between
two nearby points on the graph it's
equal to the slope of a line tangent to
the graph at a single point now notice
what I'm not saying I am NOT saying that
the derivative is whatever happens when
DT is infinitely small whatever that
would mean nor am i saying that you plug
in zero for DT this DT is always a
finitely small nonzero value it's just
that it approaches zero is all
I think that's really clever
even though change in an instant makes
no sense this idea of letting DT
approach zero is a really sneaky
backdoor way to talk reasonably about
the rate of change at a single point in
time isn't that neat it's kind of
flirting with the paradox of change in
an instant without ever needing to
actually touch it and it comes with such
a nice visual intuition too as the slope
of a tangent line to a single point on
the graph and because change in an
instant still makes no sense
I think it's healthiest for you to think
of this slope not as some instantaneous
rate of change but instead as the best
constant approximation for a rate of
change around a point by the way it's
worth saying a couple words on notation
here throughout this video I've been
using DT to refer to a tiny change in T
with some actual size and D s to refer
to the resulting change in s which again
has an actual size and this is because
that's how I want you to think about
them but the convention in calculus is
that whenever you're using the letter D
like this you're kind of announcing your
intention that eventually you're going
to see what happens as DT approaches
zero
for example the honest-to-goodness pure
math derivative is written as DS divided
by DT even though it's technically not a
fraction per se but whatever that
fraction approaches for smaller and
smaller nut is in T
I think a specific example should help
here you might think that asking about
what this ratio approaches for smaller
and smaller values would make it much
more difficult to compute but weirdly it
kind of makes things easier let's say
that you have a given distance versus
time function that happens to be exactly
T cubed so after one second
the car has traveled one cubed equals
one meters after two seconds its
traveled two cubed or eight meters and
so on now what I'm about to do might
seem somewhat complicated but once the
dust settles it really is simpler and
more importantly it's the kind of thing
that you only ever have to do once in
calculus let's say you wanted to compute
the velocity DS divided by DT at some
specific time like T equals two and for
right now let's think of DT as having an
actual size some concrete nudge will let
it go to zero in just a bit the tiny
change in distance between two seconds
and two plus DT seconds well that's s of
two plus DT minus s m2 and we divide
that by DT since our function is T cubed
that numerator looks like two plus DT
cubed minus two cubed and this this is
something we can work out algebraically
again bear with me there's a reason that
I'm showing you the details here when
you expand that top what you get is two
cubed plus three times two squared DT
plus three times two times DT squared
plus DT cubed and all of that is -2
cubed now there's a lot of terms and I
want you to remember that it looks like
a mess but it does simplify those two
cubed terms they cancel out and then
everything remaining here has a DT in it
and since there's a DT on the bottom
there many of those cancel out as well
what this means is that the ratio DS
divided by DT has boiled down into three
times two squared + well two different
terms that each have a DT in them so if
we ask what happens as DT approaches
zero representing the idea of looking at
a smaller and smaller change in time we
can just completely ignore those other
terms
by eliminating the need to think about a
specific DT we've actually eliminated a
lot of the complication in the full
expression so what we're left with is
this nice clean three times two squared
you can think of that as meaning that
the slope of a line tangent to the point
at T equals two of this graph is exactly
three times two squared where twelve and
of course there's nothing special about
the time T equals two we could more
generally say that the derivative of T
cubed as a function of T is three times
T squared
now take a step back because that's
beautiful the derivative is this crazy
complicated idea
we've got tiny changes in distance over
tiny changes in time but instead of
looking at any specific one of those
we're talking about what that thing
approaches I mean that's a lot to think
about and yet what we've come out with
is such a simple expression three times
T squared and in practice you wouldn't
go through all this algebra each time
knowing that the derivative of T cubed
is 3t squared is one of those things
that all calculus students learn how to
do immediately without having to read
arrive at each time and in the next
video I'm going to show you a nice way
to think about this and a couple other
derivative formulas in really nice
geometric ways but the point I want to
make by showing you all of the algebraic
guts here is that when you consider the
tiny change in distance caused by a tiny
change in time for some specific value
of DT you'd have kind of a mess but when
you consider what that ratio approaches
as DT approaches zero
it lets you ignore much of that mess and
it really does simplify the problem that
right there is kind of the heart of why
calculus becomes useful another reason
to show you a concrete derivative like
this is that it sets the stage for an
example of the kind of paradoxes that
come about if you believe too much in
the illusion of instantaneous rate of
change so think about the actual car
traveling according to this t-cubed
distance function and consider its
motion at the moment T equals zero right
at the start now ask yourself whether or
not the car is moving at that time
on the one hand we can compute its speed
at that point using the derivative 3t
squared which for time T equals zero
works out to be zero visually this means
that the tangent line to the graph at
that point is perfectly flat so the car
is quote unquote instantaneous velocity
is zero and that suggests that obviously
it's not moving but on the other hand if
it doesn't start moving at time zero
when does it start moving really pause
and ponder that for a moment is the car
moving at time T equals zero
do you see the paradox the issue is that
the question makes no sense it
references the idea of change in a
moment but that doesn't actually exist
that's just not what the derivative
measures what it means for the
derivative of a distance function to be
zero is that the best constant
approximation for the cars velocity
around that point is zero meters per
second for example if you look at an
actual change in time say between time
zero and 0.1 seconds the car does move
it moves 0.001 meters that's very small
and importantly it's very small compared
to the change in time giving an average
speed of only 0.01 meters per second and
remember what it means for the
derivative of this motion to be zero is
that for smaller and smaller nudges in
time this ratio of meters per second
approaches zero but that's not to say
that the car is static approximating its
movement with a constant velocity of
zero is after all just an approximation
so whenever you hear people refer to the
derivative as an instantaneous rate of
change a phrase which is intrinsically
oxymoronic I want you to think of that
as a conceptual shorthand for the best
constant approximation for rate of
change
in the next couple videos I'll be
talking more about the derivative what
it looks like in different contexts how
do you actually compute it why is it
useful things like that focusing on
visual intuition as always as I
mentioned last video this channel is
largely supported by the community
through patreon where you can get early
access to future essence of series like
this as I work on them but one other
supporter of the series who I'm
incredibly proud to feature is the art
of problem solving interestingly enough
I was actually first introduced to the
art of problem solving by my high school
calculus teacher it was the kind of
relationship where I'd frequently stick
around a bit after school just to chat
about math and he was thoughtful and
encouraging and he once gave me a book
and this book really had an influence on
me back then
it showed a certain beauty in math that
you don't really see in school and the
name of that book was the art of problem
solving fast forward to today where the
art of problem solving website offers
many many phenomenal resources for
curious students looking to get into
math
[Music]
you
[Music]
you